hello everyone my name is dinner kapadia
and i work as a kernel developer at
Wolfram research now in this
presentation I would like to give you an
introduction to the exciting new
functionality for symbolic sand numerics
in version 11 this is a vast area of
functionality including partial
differential equations differential
eigen systems symbolic a numeric
calculus and algebra and number theory
so what I'll do is to give you the
highlights for each area followed by a
brief example and then we take a tour of
the feature page for that area so let's
begin with partial differential
equations now the highlights in this
area first of all d solve can now find
some Moloch solutions of boundary value
problems for classical and modern pds
now by classical I mean things like the
heat wave and Laplace equations and on
the modern said because the Schroedinger
another pds the whole field of symbolic
solutions of pds depends upon sturm
liouville problems and we can solve
these with dissolve as well on the other
hand ND solve can now handle a periodic
boundary conditions and also events
using when event so put together this is
a very nice big improvement over earlier
versions so let's take an example of a
vibrating circular membrane so I start
with the radial wave equation I give
some boundary conditions over here to
say that for example the value of the
function is 0 at the boundary and then
it gives the problem to dissolve to
solve now we have many methods available
for this problem are the problems we've
got a Fourier transform method Laplace
transform method etc in this particular
case we use separation of variables and
so in the answer comes back it's going
to be an inactive sum which can be used
for later work so we have support for
regions and for various kinds of pds and
solving them in symbolic form now the
solution in this case is going to be an
infinite so
bolic some which I take and then one can
easily create an animation so here's the
animation of the circular membrane and
it's quite nice to see it being done
with D Saul and the new functionality so
if you'd like further examples for pds
they are available right here on the
feature page so the first row over here
is the classical PDS then here is term
level problems and the all-important
numerical solutions and finally we go
back to applications of the symbolic
solutions so we have the stretched
string quantum mechanics call options
and various are the nice options so
that's about pts and I now go on to
differential eigen systems so over here
on the first and we have the eigen
system an Indian system which can
compute symbolic and numerical values
eigen functions over regions you can
also add arbitrary time derivatives like
in the haight equation you can add
constraints to your problems and you can
solve from the couple pdso put together
this is a brand-new wonderful icon
system solver okay so an example of this
let's try and compute the acoustic item
functions for a mini so I import the
model and when that's done we will
simply discretize it like it over here
use ND eigen system and then i put
everything together and i get back the
original car along with an eigenfunction
on top so if you'd like more example of
this area here you are so that different
lighting systems we have the laplace
equation so showing the equation etc in
the first two rows for numerical icon
values that's the eigen functions or an
l-shape region we have other numerical
applications then we have the quantum
harmonic oscillator so put together this
gives you several ways of approaching
the same problem symbolically on
medically I now go on to say Moloch a
numeric calculus and over here at least
for me one important feature is the
solution of linear integral equations
which has been requested by Stephen
Wolfram and many others over the years
we can also solve large numerical
optimization problems using the IP opt
library which is now hooked up to find
minimum you can compute areas using
curvilinear coordinates not just
Cartesian coordinates and we have
brand-new functions for computing melon
transforms or functions so as an example
of integral equations but this is the
total chrome problem which requires
finding a curve down which if you place
a bead anywhere it will fall to the
bottom in exactly the same time now this
involves solving an herbal integral
equation so that's the equation we solid
D solve value and after a bit of work
you can actually simulate the total
chron and you can see over here that the
beat can start anywhere it likes but it
always reaches the bottom at exactly the
same time so there are many more
beautiful examples on the feature page
for symbolic a numeric calculus we have
the melon transforms over here
difference quotient fine minimum
integral Equis
asians greens function and then the
so-called Margie reduce which tries and
expresses functions in terms of my LG so
again we have a wonderful collection of
elementary and advanced functions for
symbolic and numeric calculus and
finally go on to algebra and number
theory so over here perhaps the most
interesting for people like number
theory is that we can now enumerate all
the Mersenne Prime's the known Mersenne
primes and Mersenne prime exponents you
can convert to and from polar spherical
coordinates that looks easy but to do it
correctly is often quite hard and we can
do it now you can specify turtle paths
using the new angle path function and
the knapsack problem is one of the
hardest problems in optimization and we
now have a wonderful function to do that
for you automatically so for Mersenne
prime exponents here's an example so
mustn't Prime exponent basically the
prime P so it must be a prime itself
such that 2 raise to P minus 1 is also a
prime number so for example if P is to
then two squares 4 and 4 minus 1 is 3
there's a prime number so here are the
first few Mersenne prime exponents once
you've got the exponents you can work
out the primes themselves some of them
are quite large and the point is that
these prime exponents are actually quite
sparsely distributed in the list of
primes so here's a graphic which shows
that and you can see quite clearly that
the red entries are the Mersenne prime
exponents and they become very sparse as
you go down the list and if you'd like
further examples for this area yours all
gibran number theory so you have the
number theory over here the polar
coordinates in spherical coordinates /
quarterly on
the knapsack problem and things like the
Smith decomposition which are pretty
useful in practice so once again the
algebra number three area is really
quite impressive for a release of
Mathematica for any reason mathematical
because we haven't had such a nice
variety in a long time I think ok so the
summarize I think version 11 includes
many exciting new features for pure and
applied mathematics we have on the one
hand number theory in other hand we have
eigenvalues problems so whether you're a
pure mathematician an applied
mathematician you will certainly enjoy
version 11 the other point is it's not
just any particular kind of use of
aiming at we are aiming for a wide range
of users to be happy with what we did so
if you're a college calculus student you
might want difference quotient and if
you're a very advanced researcher you
might want Mellin transform but who are
you are and what we like to do we have
it for you in version 11 so I really
feel quite happy and proud of what we've
done in this area for version 11 and I
hope that you will enjoy to thank you